bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro de kiosques que ce que votre
magazine dédié à la culture sur saint
quentin en yvelines et ses environs tout
de suite je vous propose de découvrir
les titres de ce mercredi 14 octobre
ophélie murray président de
l'association la divine comédie est en
plateau pour nous parler de la deuxième
édition du festival de théâtre amateur
mort de rire qui se tiendra ce week-end
du 16 au 18 octobre au théâtre gérard
philipe de saint cyr l'école hélène
gérault président de l'association
solidarité ndm france vient nous
présenter la soirée solidaire organisée
en soutien son association
vendredi 16 octobre à 20h30 au théâtre
robert emmanuel de plaisir nous y
reviendrons dans quelques instants
didier lockwood préparée il ya quelques
jours son nouveau spectacle à la mairie
de trappes un projet unique autour de
différents violents du monde pour lequel
il s'associe aux violons barbares et à
gaughan violoniste chinois et nous
démarrons cette émission avec deux
invités au filmerait présidente de
l'association la divine comédie sur
saint cyr l'école bonsoir mon frère est
hellène est géré au président de
l'association solidarité ndm france à
plaisir bonsoir alors ophélie murray ce
que vous pourriez nous présentez nous
dire un mot sur votre association la
divine comédie
oui alors c'est une association qui
vient de se créer tout juste pour
pratiquer le théâtre amateur et cette
année au nom de l'association j'ai
repris le festival mort de rire pour sa
deuxième édition
alors deuxième édition l'année dernière
c'était la première qu'est ce qui vous a
donné envie de constituer un festival de
théâtre amateur sur saint cyr et bien
pour y avoir pratiqué participé
plusieurs fois dans d'autres communes on
s'était dit que sur st cyr ça manquait
un peu et on voulait développer un petit
peu le côté culturel et donner une image
un petit peu différente du théâtre va
rester dans le côté classique ou
tragédie le théâtre aussi plein plein de
choses c'est du rire c'est de la comédie
et donc on voulait partager ça avec
d'autres troupes de théâtre amateur
priorité au tro bro 30e yvelinoise dont
trois accords voilà vous avez des
troupes de saint-cyr-l'ecole des troupes
de quels autres comme alors c'est par
choix saint cyr l'école ne sera pas en
représentation ce week-end puisque on
participe un autre spectacle dans
l'année donc là on a une troupe de
prenez en yvelines on a une troupe de
versailles poissy villepreux et on a
également une troupe d'aurillac
voilà donc ils font la route pour venir
jusque chez nous passé le week-end parmi
nous faut passer un bon moment en
théâtre et l'a10 les festivals de
théâtre c'est quelque chose qui vous
parle qui vous intéressent auquel vous
avez l'habitude de vous rendre pour que
c'est très très important
particulièrement le théâtre amateur
aussi puisque voilà je pense que tout le
monde devrait faire du théâtre rsa
développe différentes qualités
artistiques voilà desquels on en a
besoin mais entre à l'école aussi c'est
très important
c'est vrai ophélie marie hélène giraud
est ce que natacha atlas est une artiste
qui vous parle
j'en ai entendu parler après
je connais pas plus que ça
malheureusement mais elle a
elle revient sur scène et justement
avoir de poursuivre avec vous je vous
propose de découvrir quelques images de
son spectacle hier soir mardi 13 octobre
au théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
planche sur lesquels elle va nous
présenter les titres de son nouvel album
images de patrick jacq du dixmude
natacha atlas célèbre chanteuse
d'origine anglo égyptienne présentait
aux spectateurs du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines mardi soir les
titres de son nouvel album
mais ryad road projet pour lequel elle
s'est associée à ibrahim maalouf
après un an de collaboration un album
jazz aux influences orientales est né
c'est un album qui est très influencé
par le jazz on le présentait ce soir
j'ai trois chansons en arabe et ça
vraiment on entend le fusion entre
l'oriental et l'occident l'occidentale
mais vraiment dans le contexte plus jazz
landry
seul
connu pour ses reprises comme mon amie
la rose qui lui ont valu une victoire de
la musique en 1999
natacha atlas retrouve cette fois ci son
public en anglais avec de nouvelles
créations expression d'une intimité
profonde un retour sur scène avec
émotion j'ai le trac on le good vibes ou
en français j'ai appris aujourd'hui
qu'en fait une expression très long de
manière week end s'est changée extracted
cool nerveuse tous les sentiments à tous
en même temps
avant d'engager une tournée
internationale dernières dates en france
ce soir mercredi 14 octobre à paris dans
le cadre du festival mama et son album
mais ryad road sortira dans les bacs le
25 octobre prochain
pour lui
retour sur notre plateau avec nos
invités au fait les murs est présidente
de l'association la divine comédie qui
vient nous parler du de la deuxième
édition du festival amateur du théâtre
mort de rilke se tiendra donc ce week
end vendredi à dimanche à saint cyr
l'école est ce que vous attendiez au
succès qu'a rencontré la première
édition l'an passé non parce que c'était
la première édition donc c'est difficile
de se faire connaître
ce qui pose problème dans ce genre
d'événement c'est la communication et
pouvoir atteindre un petit peu tout le
monde toucher un public différent parce
qu'on a un spectacle jeune public et
c'est vrai que c'est un public difficile
à toucher en fait et vous avez réussi à
fédérer à attirer les jeunes comme les
familles comme les moins jeunes oui tout
à fait c'est très très éclectique allons
peut-être présentez-nous les cinq
spectacles quelques spectacles qui qui
formeront le programme du festival ce
week end
oui alors on à la pièce toc toc
écrite par laurent baffie donkey théâtre
de boulevard
donc on rit beaucoup voilà qu'est ce
qu'on peut en dire
du rire du tout à fait beaucoup beaucoup
et on reçoit également une compagnie
pour un spectacle jeune public donc le
samedi après midi qui s'appelle cours y
vite il va filer
donc c'est plutôt ça s'articule autour
des clowns et on organise d'ailleurs à
ce titre un atelier le matin animée par
amélie charbonnier donc voilà s'il ya
des enfants qui souhaitent venir y
participer c'est gratuit de 11h à 12h
voilà saint cyr l'école ou encore un
atelier autour du cloud et la naissance
de clown la naissance de chloé voilà
ensuite on a un spectacle alors que
malheureusement je n'ai pas vu donc ce
sera une surprise pour moi également
burlingue à part la compagnie dl / ville
preuve donc je ne pourrais pas vous en
parler
et chacun sa croix de la compagnie
d'aurillac
donc c'est pareil c'est du comics encore
une fois avec un maire un prêtre tout le
monde s'y perd un peu là dedans ça va de
quiproquos et situations un peu cocasse
elle vous inviter tous les gens qui
veulent venir passer un bon moment tout
à fait au théâtre merci beaucoup hélène
giraud présidente de l'association
solidarité ndm france alors cette cette
association travaille en collaboration
pour le soutien d'un village au vietnam
ce que vous pourriez nous la présenter
un petit peu plus
alors non pas du tout au vietnam mes
parents je croyais au sénégal au sénégal
gas corp voilà donc c'est une
association de solidarité effectivement
qui soutient des projets de
développement dans la région de ndem au
sénégal cette zone de ndem se trouve à
120 km à l'est de dakar et c'est une
zone très défavorisés en brousse mais où
depuis 30 ans existe un projet de
développement exceptionnelles et donc
nous soutenons les villageois pour les
aider à rester au village et à
développer tout leur toutes leurs
compétences mais aussi lors on parle de
quelconques et en fait ce que c'est du
troll air pour les enfants est ce que
c'est l'infrastructure est ce que c'est
médical voilà il ya tout ça donc
effectivement il ya des écoles la prose
et développement un vrai projet de
développement avec des écoles
maternelles
primaires collèges postes de santé case
de santé encore plus loin que haine des
membres ou ce projet de maraîchage
biologique centre artisanal casas
vétérinaire etc etc
tant que les besoins sont énormes et
nous nous répondons à l'heure quand ils
ont ils ont tous beaucoup beaucoup de
projets et quand nous essayons de
répondre alors à leurs besoins dans la
mesure aussi nos limites bien sûr et ce
genre de projet nécessité des fonds et à
cette occasion vous organisez une soirée
solidaire qui aura lieu vendredi 16
octobre prochain au théâtre robert
manuel de plaisir oui vous avez fait
appel à une compagnie qui est la
compagnie zigomatik louis ce qui est une
raison particulière pour laquelle vous
avez fait appel à cette compagnie alors
nous avons fait appel à eux parce que
nous les avons rencontrés au salon des
solidarités à paris en 2013 et que
surtout le sujet de leur pièce est le
titre de la pièce nous a interpellé
puisque c'est aussi ce sont nos
problématiques également ça s'appelle le
grand jeu de la fin et faillit m
et donc nous nous travaillons sur ces
problématiques de et bien d'alimentation
au sud puisque un demi pas grand chose
qui pousse donc voilà on les aide pour
un gros projet de maraîchage biologique
mais ce qui est intéressant je pensais
que ce qui sera intéressant vendredi
dans cette pièce de théâtre c'est que
c'est très drôle très burlesque et donc
voilà on va c'est une moi je dis que
c'est une façon de se conscientiser de
voilà de sensibiliser les gens et les
citoyens actifs mais à travers l'humour
le rire
voilà donc ce sera pas ennuyeux du tout
alors avant de détailler un peu plus sur
cette compagnie
je vous propose de faire un petit retour
sur la résidence artistique qui a eu
lieu la semaine dernière à la merise de
trappes pendant laquelle et didier
lockwood et les violons barbares
accompagné du violoniste chinois gaughan
préparer leur tout nouveau spectacle
images dès jeudi moines
en résidence artistique pendant trois
jours à la merise de trappes mi octobre
l'idylle hop ou de préparer son nouveau
spectacle en 40 ans de carrière il n'a
cessé d'explorer les richesses de son
instrument le violon il revient avec un
projet unique autour des violons du
monde pour lequel ils cessent aussi aux
violons barbares et à google comme
j'avais un projet sur les violons du
monde j'ai décidé de de leur demander de
une colonne collaborent ensemble pour
pouvoir monter un projet autour de ces
musiques qu'empruntent les différents
violon du monde et donc il y associer
aussi les biologistes chinois gaughan
avec son héros donc là on en fait on a
pratiquement un quatuor de violon du
monde
cinq artistes sur scène pour mêler
joyeusement violon traditionnel bulgare
chinois mongol mêmes électrique avec le
vieux lectra quatre cordes frottées pour
offrir un spectacle arrangements rock
porté par des percussions effréné
t
pourquoi
un projet exceptionnel pour faire vivre
et découvrir la musique traditionnelle
au travers d'une vision contemporaine
virtuose et décalé en résulte un
spectacle surprenant et plein d'énergie
je joue ma musique si noah traditionnel
avec l'autre moi j'aime pas toujours
traditionnels se traite 1 tradition des
solos quand même j'aime beaucoup
rencontrent et jouer avec notre musique
le classique parole cette fois c'est ce
projet c'est le cas c'est unir les deux
premiers morceaux le public et c'est
parce que ce qui lui arrive déjà qu'est
ce que c'est ces instruments là qu'est
ce que c'est que cette énergie d'où ça
vient et petit à petit ça ça rentre je
rentre dans la musique est lui aussi
beaucoup de voix elle est la voir ça
parle à tout le monde même s'ils sont
comprend pas la langue
rendez vous pour découvrir ces virtuoses
des violons du monde le samedi 23
janvier 2016 à la merise de trappes à
20h30
et nous retrouvons un plateau nos
invités ophélie muret pour l'association
la divine comédie hélène géraud pour
l'association solidarité ndm france
impression la virtuosité de didier
lockwood et et des violons barbares non
oui tout à fait lui ce très dynamique
c'est sympa alors leur spectacle serait
le samedi 23 janvier à la maurice de
trappes ce que vous pensez faire un
petit tour pourquoi pas peut-être c'est
la musique traditionnelle revisitée dans
le contemporain c'est quelque chose
qu'ils ne connaissent pas assez qu'il
faut promouvoir je pense et l'algérie
vont nous expliquer tout à l'heure que
vous aviez fait appel à la compagnie
zigomatik qui défend des qui
partageaient un peu les mêmes les mêmes
questionnements sur la vie comme la
société transformation les absurdités
qu'on peut trouver économique
alimentaire écologique est une industrie
agro chimique qui peut soulever
certaines questions
je vous propose tout de suite de les
découvrir en scène
j'ai alors il s'agit donc d'une troupe
de comédiens chanteurs au registre
burlesque net-citoyens ils feront partie
de la programmation de cette soirée
qu'est-ce qu'on pourra retrouver
également après avant pendant le
spectacle
alors il y aura une exposition de ce
projet de maraîchage biologique
essentiellement mais aussi de notre de
nos autres projets de développement dans
ce village
nous sommes aussi en partenariat nous
organisons cette soirée en partenariat
avec trois autres associations donc
chacune aura aussi la possibilité de
faire connaître ce qu'ils font donc il y
aura le artisans du monde le ccfd comité
catholique contre la faim et pour le
développement ainsi que la map de
plaisir la map des saveurs il y aura une
vente d'artisanat il y aura
voilà essentiellement et je voudrais
quand même dire que l'après midi il y
aura une séance pour les lycéens du
lycée jean vilar de plaisir et ça je
trouve que c'est très très important que
150 élèves alors ils le verront
l'après-midi d'accord il ya donc un
spectacle tout public le soir pour les
adultes et les jeunes
en mai il y aura aussi 150 élèves de
seconde du lycée jean vilar qui seront
là l'après midi et ça je trouve ça
formidable qu'ils puissent assister à
cette pièce parce que je pense que c'est
bien que des jeunes aillent au théâtre
aussi alors cette soirée solidaire
viendra divertir comme vous le disiez et
poser des questions mais également elle
viendra remercié en martinair important
oui oui tout à fait parce que c'est la
fin d'un projet de ce projet de
maraîchage biologique et qui a été
soutenu financièrement par le conseil
départemental des yvelines et donc à
l'occasion de cette soirée nous les
remercions d'avoir soutenu notre projet
de nous avoir aidés à le réaliser
très bien ophélie muret landes 0 merci
d'être venus aujourd'hui en plateau et
je rappelle que l'on pourra vous
retrouvez alors au film murray dans le
cadre du festival de théâtre amateur
mort de rire de vendredi à dimanche
tous les jours au théâtre gérard philipe
à saint cyr l'école et pour la soirée
solidaire exceptionnelle vendredi 16
octobre à 20h30 au théâtre robert manuel
de deux plaisirs on poursuit cette
soirée avec une exposition particulière
à versailles louis de versailles qui est
proposée jusqu'au 16 janvier à la
bibliothèque municipale
une exposition qui retrace le règne de
louis xiv et l'essor de la ville de
versailles qui a quasiment garder sa
géographie du xviie siècle images de
patrick jacques de dixmude la
bibliothèque municipale de versailles
présente jusqu'au 16 janvier
l'exposition we de versailles dans le
cadre du tricentenaire de la mort du roi
soleil
elle retrace la vie de son monarque et
l'essor de la ville modelé par la seule
volonté royale louis xiv où l'eau à tout
prix quitter paris et affectionnons
versailles pour ces terrains de chasse
c'est un village de 400 ou 500 âmes
à la fin du règne versailles à la
dimension d'une ville de bord d'une
ville comme bordeaux alors que ça n'est
ni un port ça n'est pas une ville qui
est non plus sur des voies de
communication importante ça n'est pas un
noeud commercial important
par conséquent cette ville devenue
importante les vraiment là vraiment été
par la volonté royale la cour s'installe
à versailles en 782 et ce sera la
capitale jusqu'à la fin d'ancien régime
bibliothèque municipale un chiffre
commune à l'école des beaux arts de
versailles et musée lambinet conjuguent
leurs collections et aux fonds publics
des pièces exceptionnelles comme l'acte
de naissance de louis xiv
des portraits d'époque des estampes
contemporaines et gravures d'origine il
s'agit du carrousel le louis xiv qui
fait référence à un événement qui est
lui en 762 pour le roi c'est une c'est
la première occasion de manifester en
fait son pouvoir retrouver puisque dans
ce carrousel sont invités à le suivre
derrière l'ensemble des princes de la
noblesse française c'est donc un
manifeste politique pour louis xiv qui
apparaît en empereur des romains l'
empire romain étant à l'époque la
légitimité absolue en termes politiques
les versailles et pourront même s'amuser
à contempler le très grand parcellaire
fidèle à la géographie de la ville à la
fin du dix septième siècle cartographie
sur laquelle on retrouve les trois
grandes avenues de versailles qui
convergent vers le château apologie du
pouvoir royal et je vous propose
maintenant une autre exposition cette
fois ci à plaisir
la bibliothèque du château de plaisir
présente kakémonos kazako jusqu'au 30
novembre une exposition de formats
kakémonos façon vitrail proposé par dix
résidants de l'hôpital plaisir grignon
en situation de handicap
ces créations artistiques sont réalisés
dans le cadre d'ateliers pour insérer en
situation ordinaire des personnes
présentant différents handicaps
l'expo consiste en un format spécifique
kakémonos qui est un format japonais
comme vous pouvez le voir derrière moi
et pourquoi la transparence tout
simplement parce que les résidents qui
participent à cette exposition participe
aussi à une activité de vendredi matin
par semaine où ils sont en insertion
complète en milieu ordinaire au sein du
musée
une pratique des activités différentes
qui peuvent être le dessin la peinture
le pastel et c est tout de suite notre
chronique cinéma je vous propose de
retrouver ensemble les nouveautés à la
fiche de ce mercredi 14 octobre
qu'en pensez vous vos avis au micro de
camille lambert
heureusement qu'il avait pris sa caméra
après dix ans de repos on se laisse
embarquer oui complètement
les acteurs sensationnel gilles
lellouche mathieu amalric tout le monde
très enlevé très très dynamique super
c'est un film qui est trépidant n'a pas
le temps de s'endormir ya de l'action en
permanence c'est un film remarquable que
je conseille à tout le monde et je
trouve que c'est très compliqué quoi ça
part dans tous les sens ça court dans
tous les sens et beaucoup de vent trop
long pas plausible bois c'est donc je
m'attendais pas à un grand chaleur mais
bon voilà ça se regarde c'est gentil on
retrouve on retrouve le comment dire le
côté humoristique où on peut avoir avec
la dame voit la super film je dirais pas
que c'est un de ses meilleurs mais il
fait partie des meilleurs
l'intrigué bien et puis c'est tout c'est
c'est toutes ces peurs lui tout c'est
comme d'habitude quoi qu'il transcrit ça
à l'image c'est vraiment bien j'ai
trouvé ça un peu dans le style de match
pologne peut être un petit peu moins
pervers mais j'ai trouvé ça très très
bien j'ai beaucoup aimé ma stone joaquin
phoenix l'atmosphère fois j'ai trouvé ça
vraiment bien et pour le coup de coeur
professionnels cette semaine c'est
aurélie sergent du grenier à sel de
trappes qui nous informent sur les
nouveautés à la fiche le grenelle
accorde une attention particulière sur
ce mois d'octobre au film pour les
jeunes spectateurs
ils les auront droit à voir différents
programmes de courts métrages ou des
films plutôt porteur mais tous de
qualité pour les plus petits avec le
zoom l'occasion de voir des deux
programmes de courts métrages le premier
temps les fables de monsieur renard où
ils retrouveront le personnage du renard
sur chacun des courts métrages ce qui
leur permettra de bien suivre les
histoires dans la mesure où ce programme
s'adresse aux tout petits aux enfants à
partir de 3 ans on connaît le renard
comme un être rusé un être curieux à
notre intelligence ce sera le cas dans
ce programme de
au métrage et ils auront encore
l'occasion de voir un autre programme
qui s'appelle des petites casseroles ou
là ce sont six histoires toutes
différentes et qui ont comme point
commun la différence je pense notamment
à un court métrage qui est très beau qui
est un court métrage irlandais ou un
petit oiseau doit émigrer mais il a
cette fois je voulais pratiquer l'être
pour les plus grands notamment les
enfants entre 6 et 10 11 ans ils auront
l'occasion de re voir s'ils n'ont pas
encore découvert vice versa qui est donc
un film des studios tout s'arrête ici ou
là il s'agit d'une petite fille qui doit
apprendre à contrôler feuille de match
où il y aura également au tél 36 de
rennes 2 qui est donc la suite du
premier hôtel transylvanie donc ce film
là la fille de dracula a eu un enfant
avec un lit main et ce petit gars on va
donc être initié par son grand-père
vampire à l'art de devenir vampire
bien sûr tout ceci étant dans une
ambiance tout à fait détendu et très
drôle
il suffit de faire se lance pas peur et
vous aurez aussi également fantôme boy
qui est un long métrage sorti des
studios français qui s'appelle folimage
où là c'est l'histoire d'un petit garçon
qui fait leo qui a 12 ans et qui va être
aidé d'un policier annexes
ensemble essayer de sauver la ville de
new york donc c'est à la fois un très
beau film graphiquement et c'est aussi
une belle histoire policière donc vous
serez prêt dans un récit
avec un rythme très intense voilà donc
on espère que les plus jeunes
spectateurs accompagnés de leurs parents
seront ravis de venir au mois d'octobre
au grenier à sel
merci et avant de nous quitter je vous
propose comme chaque semaine quelques
dates à noter dans vos agendas pour un
week-end tout en culture
vendredi 16 octobre à 20h30 à la salle
jacques-brel de montigny le bretonneux
faada freddy vous entraînera au rythme
de sa voix soul et de ses percussions
corporelles
samedi 17 octobre à 20h30 reprise de la
saison des concerts pour la salle de la
tour de voisins-le-bretonneux les
studios mais ta sauce propose trois
groupes collatéral le fameux groupe
volutes qui vient de sortir son dernier
rhdp et dernier cri on écoute un extrait
tu prends savoir mme et une série 1 du
fort pouvoir que tu détiens
on reste en musique je vous propose de
dimanche 18 octobre à 17 heures un
concert de l'ensemble vocal yves dulac à
l'église de saint germain de magny les
hameaux
vous pourrez y entendre des chants
orthodoxes a accompagné par un orgue fin
du kiosque pour cette semaine
émission à voir et à revoir sur notre
site internet
je vous retrouverai avec plaisir
mercredi prochain 21 octobre très bonne
soirée à tous